[Music]
get up here you big lump
no one must know there are dragons in
the valley
fire drake stay out of trouble what was
that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh a paradise
for dragons we could go there and lead
everyone to safety how are you planning
to get that
i've got wings haven't i
inspired by cornelia funka's
best-selling book so
genius where do we start
hi you're him
yeah climb aboard dragon rider
all humans are liars and chiefs you're a
fake you're not a
dragon biter was that
my pants yes tell them who
let's get out of here
[Applause]
look at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for refreshments
i'm trying to be mystical was an
arranged marriage
you are much more than you think you are
follow your heart and the truth will
come to you
ready ready join a gang of unlikely
friends
[Music]
yep
dragon rider so we have two next
partners some more
coming soon
[Music]
you